Speaker 1: Donald Trump's former CFO is going to
jail. We're talking about Allen Weisselberg. He
has indeed been sentenced. And this is starting
to get closer and closer and closer to the inner
circle of the Trump world. CNBC reports Former
Trump Organization CFO Allen Weisselberg sent
to jail for five months in the tax fraud case.
Former Trump Organization chief Financial officer
Allen Weisselberg was sentenced to five months in
jail after pleading guilty to multiple tax crimes
related to former President Trump's businesses.
Weisselberg was expected to begin serving his
jail term in New York City's notorious Rikers
Island facility following a sentencing hearing.
Weisselberg and several of Trump's business
entities were charged in what prosecutors called
a systematic scheme to defraud state and federal
tax authorities spanning more than 15 years. The
article goes on to say that the 75 year old was
handcuffed and led out of a manhattan courtroom
shortly after 230 Eastern with a very brief
sentencing hearing before the state judge,
Juan Merkin. He will be immediately transported
to Rikers Island. Now, some of you were saying,
David, sir, I'm crying because Weisselberg isn't
being shipped up to one of those swankier federal
facilities. My understanding is that because his
sentence is shorter, I believe, under a year,
although fact check me on that. He goes to jail
rather than prison. And based on the location,
it's Rikers, which is not exactly a place you want
to spend too much time if you can avoid it. Now,
of course, the questions continue to be Georgia
grand jury is done and we will soon know whether
Trump is getting indicted there. January 6th
Committee is done. That was in the last Congress.
Now it's Republicans control the House. January
six committee is done. January six committee of
the previous Congress made a criminal referral of
Trump and others to the Department of Justice. We
are waiting there to see whether Merrick Garland
will, as some like to say, have the testicular
fortitude to charge Donald Trump. And then
third, we've got things happening in New York,
and those relate to Trump's business in great
part and other things. And there remains a sort
of general question mark as to whether there may
be charges there. So we may end up with no charges
against Trump. We may end up with charges from one
of these areas, New York, Georgia. Federal charges
could be two and it could be three if it's three.
And I don't think that that's particularly likely.
What does it do for Trump's campaign? And is Trump
actually looking to bail on the campaign anyway,
given how disastrously it's going? Questions We
will hopefully soon answer all of the clips I've
played here. You can find on our Instagram
at David Pakman show. And please, please,
please make sure that you are subscribed to the
YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. You know, there's this thing called
the bystander effect. People walk by. Someone's
being brutally beaten on the street. No one
calls the police because they assume someone
else is going to call. Real Story from history.
Don't allow the bystander effect of someone else
will subscribe and help them get to 2 million
subscribers on YouTube. Don't fall for that.
Be the person. It costs nothing. It's just a click
and you get us one step closer to an incredible
milestone 2 million YouTube subscribers. One of
our sponsors today is Magic Spoon the breakfast
cereal with the crunchy sweet goodness you love,
but with high quality ingredients less sugar and
more protein. Magic spoon has zero grams of sugar.
It's packed with 13 to 14 grams of protein and
just 4 to 5 net carbs. So it's great if you're
doing keto or low carb or if just like me,
you're trying to limit your sugar intake. They
have many unique flavors so you'll never get
bored. My personal favorite is Maple Waffle, but I
grew up in New England, so maybe that's why Maple,
you know, they also have cocoa. Fruity
frosted, peanut butter, blueberry muffin,
honey nut cookies and cream, cinnamon roll.
Sometimes there's really just no substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of cereal.
Who doesn't love that? When the mood strikes
go for something more wholesome, with plenty of
protein and without all the sugar. If you don't
love magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does, Magic spoon will refund all of your money,
no questions asked. Simply go to magic
spoon dot com slash pacman. You can
create a custom bundle and use the code
pacman for $5 off. The link is down below.